[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode Kos
and today we have sideshows Premium
Format Wonder Woman now I brought you a
Wonder Woman before that Wonder Woman
was from the og DC's Holy Trinity and
this is the new DC's Holy Trinity the
new Holy Trinity is based off of the new
52 line that's after DC decided to
restructure revamp switch things around
to get these new storylines new art
directions new concepts out now
initially the new 52 one woman's suit is
blue and red and post a picture right
here so you can see I'm not really
feeling that you know that's not my
thing what I'm used to like I told you
before when I did the last video of Kos
fill us with Wonder Woman is that the
Lynda Carter you know the the beautiful
Wonder Woman the music that that she has
that she was a movement for the feminist
movement and the woman's movement
you know to show that female super arrow
is just as strong as a male superhero
she can get things done on the same
wavelength and let me tell you something
one woman is a very accomplished
combatted all right
so we all know the story of one woman
she's the daughter of Zeus made out of
clay come to life and she's hit
she says she stays on the Amazon island
with the rest of the Amazon and she
decided to venture out and give her
power to the world she fell in love with
a human which to me makes absolutely no
sense you know to my opinion in my
opinion the latest stuff with Frank
Miller would hire Wonder Woman and
Superman having a baby I thought that
was fantastic I thought that was the the
lane that she was supposed to be in
she's supposed to be with the alpha male
inside the room even though we know our
Batman is a super alpha male when it
comes to his percent man his persona
Superman plays like a beta male but he's
really an alpha male you know I thought
that that marriage that
the uniqueness of it would lend to
better storyteller at least we did get
that at least we did get a lot of things
out of that storyline which is really
good
go back to this storyline in its statute
initially I wasn't gonna pick up the
statute and tell I soul how robust is
she is she is literally staggering
beautiful the portrait alone on this
statue is how can I say in its its how
new portraits should be the hair sculpt
the the facial the eyes beautiful the
head then everything is beautiful the
arms the legs the body the robust is too
strong mr. statute she has gravitas in a
statue format beautiful
the base is done impeccably if you see
the base you can tell the base has a lot
of Centurion heads and they have the
masts on and stuff like that but the
base is like a stone pillar base like
steps going up with flame cauldrons
around now what I found amazing is that
the flame cauldrons actually light up so
haha Google cream so the flame cauldrons
light up what you do is you can plug it
in and it is shown I was kind of
disappointed it because I like the fact
that you can put batteries inside so
many statues and the batteries because
you're not usually next to an outlet
alright so you have to come up with a
lot of trickery to get the portable
lithium batteries and plug it in to show
the light of features of the statute
I thought the sections the base was
beautiful in that regard is a very heavy
base very detailed the light-up features
welcome in the dark it looks and
beautiful and it flickers right so you
go up to the boot is not the traditional
Wonder Woman boots these boots is
reimagined I'm gonna tell you sideshows
way the shield on her back is impeccably
done the sword is fantastic you you
really have to understand that the level
of detail done to these statues now are
on a whole nother level you see the
dynamic poles with the head swing in one
way
and the bodies is shifting in another
way and she's throwing the lasso it's
about time that the magic lasso takes a
step to the forefront because that's one
of her main weapons you know so is great
to see that they have that net shown so
after I saw that the Holy Trinity I said
you know I'm going to complete it that
her batman/superman yes it needed to be
done I'm going to do a comparison video
with og Wonder Woman versus the new 52
Wonder Woman and to see which who y'all
like the most you know leave the
comments down below I answer comments I
talk to you guys back and forth let me
know what y'all feel how you feel about
it and what y'all think about the
statute I think she's beautiful she's
ravishing
she looks phenomenal especially for a
spoke of this nature you can see she's a
little bit more mature but quality you
know
trust me the other og statue
shoot a little skinny choose a Lupin I
don't like him like that this is more to
my liking this is the style that's
fantastic
it's beautiful so this is part of the
video when I tell you if you like what
you heard like follow and subscribe and
also go to Lords of gaming dotnet where
we have all the Kos statues of their
combat talk with the King for myself oh
man
so destiny 2 has just released and the
last word with Lord Cognito and bonta's
is up they go into destiny like no other
listen is a great view you can watch it
on Fridays and also we have our hardcore
reviews when Lord attic we have tons of
opinion pieces up there as well check
out the site I'm sure you'll love it
I'm not saying it because I'm a part of
it but I'm just saying also stick around
to watch the statue in all its glory
with a ton of pictures
next week I got something special for
you guys I got a guy coming in statue
and if he gets here in time
then that statue will take presidents
over a statute that I'm gonna have for
you that's sitting right over there on
the side ready to rock but um they've
got other statue shows up you're
definitely gonna get that statue so
scale Wes see you next week
[Music]